vous avez été tous formidables et nous
avons vraiment apprécié les
interventions multiples variées
complémentaire et et évidemment nous
nous avons quelque peu la réponse à la
question que nous devons nous poser
essentiellement c'est pourquoi
voulons-nous refonder notre système
social pour 2017 c'était une question
qu'on devait se poser et je crois que
vous y avez déjà apporté une très grande
réponse le monde a changé sans que notre
organisation sociale s'adapte à ces
changements et et et l'attachement des
fr des Français au modèle social n'est
pas un signe de confiance dans le modèle
lui-même c'est-à-dire dans son
organisation et sa gouvernance mais tout
simplement dans les valeurs dans les
valeurs qu'il
véhicule nous voulons un système
protecteur fidèle justement à cette
justice sociale que nous avions instauré
dans les ordonnances fondatrices de 45
mais nous vouons aussi que que ça soit
la seule garantie de sa pérennité qu'il
il soit économiquement viable qu'il soit
surtout juste pour qu'il soit acceptable
par tous bref en gros rien n'est simple
et pour bien faire très sincèrement vous
tous qui êtes là mais j'espère que nous
ferons adhérer celles et ceux qui ne
nous écoutent pas nous devons bousculer
nos habitudes celles de nos
administrations et même celles des
responsables politiques notre système
social a des forces considérables mais
aussi de très grandes marges
d'amélioration oui l'amélior améliorer
son efficience permettra de dégager les
moyens nécessaires pour tous les
Français qui en auront besoin en
maintenant un haut niveau de qualité et
d'accessibilité nous avons fait le choix
de la
lucidité du courage notamment pour ne
pas faire supporter sur les générations
qui suivent cette dette connue de tous
est devenue inacceptable nous
concentrerons les moyens les efforts sur
les véritables priorités d'aujourd'hui
et c'est ce que Eric WT nous a expliqué
alors ce qui nous est important et et
nous l'avons entendu dans la dernière
table ronde c'est l'égal accès au soins
qui on l'a compris sera le fruit d'un
projet politique de territoire car nous
vivons dans les territoires les hôpitaux
les cliniques travaillent ensemble les
médecins libéraux bien sûr les
associations de de patients qui sont
intervenus mais je n'oublie pas tous les
professionnels de santé et
particulièrement les infirmières je suis
une ancienne infirmière et croyez-moi
vous pouvez me faire confiance pour que
le rôle de l'infirmière soit bien pris
en considération dans toute cette
refondation de notre système social et
de santé alors ce qui est important pour
tout le monde je crois pour tout le
monde c'est une grande stabilité et une
lisibilité des objectifs et des
sanctions négatives bien sûr mais
également positives Monsieur Raymond
c'est en cela que nous voulons aussi
travailler c'est pour que tout cela
évidemment il soit associés les
priorités de notre famille politique
propose véritablement en direction des
besoins de chacun évidemment la
refondation de la famille en tout cas de
ce qui a été détérioré par le
gouvernement en place la santé nous
l'avons exposé les personnes handicapées
nous allons en parler la dépendance
sujet de priorité de je crois chaque
Français parce qu'elle nous concernera
demain ù elle concerne déjà nos parents
bien sûr concernant la retraite et la
pauvreté qui progresse par ce manque
d'économie aujourd'hui voilà notre
méthode est claire et transparente dire
avant ce que nous ferons après voilà
pourquoi j'appelle d'ors et déjà
Catherine drendler pour qu'elle puisse
nous parler de la famille puisque la
famille a été largement malmené par les
gouvern ce gouvernement socialiste ces
dernières années une longue série
d'attaques hein vraiment sur la famille
avec malheureusement une baisse des
naissances à peu près de 2,3 %
alors que Nicolas Sarkozi avait bien sûr
eu cette priorité la famille j'en parle
en tant qu'ancienne secrétaire d'État à
la famille puisque le PIB avait été
augmenté pour la famille il était passé
de 4,7 à 5,1 il faut absolument le
remarquer les modes de garde étaient en
pleine évolution pour concilier vie
familiale et vie professionnelle voilà
ce dont va aborder comme sujet ma chère
Catherine qui est sénatrice et que je
vous présente à l'instant je te demande
de vir à la
tribune alors Catherine et sénatrice et
en charge en tant que déléguée national
de la
famille merci beaucoup madame la
déléguée générale aux affaires sociales
très chè Claude mesdames et messieurs
c'est un grand honneur pour moi de
pouvoir aborder ce sujet
majeur au niveau de l'impact dans notre
société qui est la famille je
l'aborderai aujourd'hui sous le prisme
un petit peu contraint de cette
convention mais je vous invite d'ors et
déjà à vous associer à une petite
convention que nous allons organiser
entièrement dédiée aux problématiques
très larges de la famille le 9 juin
prochain dès la libération de notre pays
il était nécessaire de relever pour
relever la France d'encourager les
naissances et soutenir les familles et
pour ce faire notamment nous avons créé
la sécurité sociale notre famille
politique alors mis un point d'honneur à
développer des politiques en ce sens
soutenir la famille c'est défendre
l'égalité hommes-femme c'est défendre un
pilier économique essentiel de notre
société et c'est défendre aussi un Fab
fabuleux outil de cohésion
sociale mettre en place une vraie
politique familiale ambitieuse et donc
capitale pour notre pays accompagner
financièrement les familles en
compensant les charges inhérentes à
l'accueil d'un enfant et permettre aux
parents de concilier vie familiale et
vie professionnelle doit devenir un
objectif prioritaire cela est d'autant
plus essentiel que la famille est au
cœur de tous les sujets traités
aujourd'hui lors de cette
convention c'est un soutien dans les
moments difficiles elle est
indispensable lors des périodes de
construction de l'enfant et elle reste
le le cadre où se développe l'individu
et le
citoyen or nous le savons tous le
contexte actuel est plus qu'alarmant
alors que la famille reste plébiscitée
par les Français en particulier chez les
jeunes la politique familiale est source
de crainte chez les couples ce qui
freine la
natalité les mutations de la famille ne
sont pas ne sont plus accompagnées par
cette politique d'une part au sein du
territoire français les inégalités sont
criantes entre les territoires urbains
périurbain et ruraux d'autre part les
familles monoparentales don don le
nombre est croissant et où l'enfant est
souvent à la charge de la mère et bien
il peine à s'en sortir et c'est peu dire
même si un couple est solide que de que
que de difficulté pour faire garder son
enfant l'offre qui accompagnait la
demande dans ce domaine pendant plus de
10 ans
s'essouffle de même que les promesses de
François Hollande de créer 275000
nouvelles solutions d'accueil dont
100000 places en crèche la situation
catastrophique de la famille résulte
d'une politique familiale irresponsable
de la gauche qu'il nous faut corriger
lorsque nous accéderons au pouvoir
oui je l'affirme la famille a été
particulièrement malmenée par les
gouvernements socialistes ces dernières
années j'en ve j'en veux pour preuve des
chiffres l'INC a publié début 2016 le
nombre des naissances en France pour
l'année 2015 cette étude a montré une
baisse de près de 2,3 % des naissances
par rapport à l'année précédente
ainsi les naissances n'ont jamais été
aussi peu nombreuses depuis
1999 pour la première fois depuis fort
longtemps le nombre d'enfants par femme
en âge de procré
1,96 enfants par femme en 2015 passe en
dessous du seuil symbolique de deux soit
le seuil de renouvellement cette baisse
inquiétante s'explique entre autres par
une perte de confiance des couples en
âge de procurer et le souhaitant dans
les politiques publiques et pu partic
parulrement dans les politiques
familiales bien évidemment la natalité
pour les couples est avant tout un signe
de confiance en
l'avenir les couples approuvent le
besoin éprouvent pardon le besoin
d'avoir de bonnes perspectives d'emploi
de finances de logement mais aussi de
garde afin d'envisager sereinement
d'avoir des enfants en plus du en plus
grand nombre la famille assure le
renouvellement des générations la
transmission de notre culture c'est elle
qui est dépositaire de ce lien
intergénérationnel si précieux pour nos
sociétés de cette solidarité
essentielle depuis
2012 le gouvernement socialiste méprise
les
familles cela s'est vu au fil des
politiques familiales mises en œuvre
l'entrée en vigueur en juillet dernier
de la réforme des allocations familiales
conditionné au revenus est le parfait
exemple il entérine la fin du principe
d'un d'universalité des prestations
familiale ainsi concrètement les
familles gagnant plus de 6000 € par mois
voi à présent leur allocation divisé par
2 et ceci après une longue série
d'attaques contre les familles avec
notamment les deux coups de rabau du
ctiion familial la fiscalisation de la
majoration de pension pour retraiter
parents de famille nombreuses la
division par deux à partir du 2e enfant
de la prime de naissance la baisse du
complément du mode de garde et aussi la
diminution de la durée du congé parental
finalement ce sont quelques 3,2 millions
de familles qui verront leur aide
familiale baisser sévèrement d'ici 2017
alors que ce sont seul 2,1 million de
familles qui percevront une aide
complémentaire ainsi depuis l'élection
de François Hollande très important il
est demandé aux familles pour 4
milliards d'euros
d'effort ces politiques familiales vont
à contre de la marge de l'histoire à
l'encontre des vertus qu'elles ont
démontré depuis 1945 et finalement à
l'encontre du bon sens puisque même les
Allemands même les Allemands cherchent
aujourd'hui à copier notre modèle ou
peut-être devrais-je plutôt dire notre
ancien modèle ce climat anxiogène pour
les familles mis en place par les
gouvernements socialistes trouve sa
traduction dans cette mauvaise
statistique de 1900 de 2015 pour le
nombre de naissances en France
d'ailleurs Claude en a parlé également
dans l'intod
production alors nos propositions les
républicains souhaitent défendre une
politique familiale ambitieuse juste et
volontariste nous pensons que les
contributeurs au financement du système
doivent pouvoir continuer à en
bénéficier au risque sinon de développer
des attitudes de ralbol fiscal et de
retrait de pacte
social notre parti doit d'abord
réaffirmer avec force et conviction
plutôt que d'opposer les citoyens entre
riches et pauvres entre ceux qui ont des
enfants et ceux qui n'en ont
pas la politique familiale vise
essentiellement à compenser le poids
financier que représente un enfant pour
inciter les couples quel que soit leur
niveau de revenu à accroître le nombre
de naissance à la politique familiale la
responsabilité de porter son ambition à
la politique fiscale la responsabilité
d'assujétir les foyers fiscaux à un taux
de prélèvement débattu chaque année
devant le Parlement
en outre si la politique fiscale a
besoin de stabilité pour les acteurs
économiques les ménages les entreprises
c'est encore plus vrai pour la politique
familiale car elle elle engage des choix
de vie logement vie professionnelle
organisation de la cellule familiale
pour étailler cette affirmation je vous
propose une seule illustration
chiffrée avant redistribution les
couples monoactifs sans enfant ont en
moyenne un niveau de vie de plus de 2400
€ par mois donné 2014 soit 1,5 fois plus
élevé que celui des couples monoactifs
avec un ou deux
enfants et 2,2 fois plus élevé que ceux
avec trois enfants ou plus chacun est
responsable de ses choix et doit les
assumer financièrement mais la société
si elle veut assurer sa pérennité doit
faire en sorte d'encourager les famill
qui pourrait hésiter à avoir des enfants
pour des questions de moyens parler avec
ma collègue tout à l'heure en effet
l'impôt sur le revenu doit être le
vecteur de l'équité chacun doit
contribuer à l'impôt selon ses
possibilités la politique familiale n'a
pas cet objectif la pr les prestations
doivent être égales pour tous quel que
soit le niveau de revenu aussi en
s'attaquant à ce principe d'universalité
c'est à l'un des des principes du pacte
républicain que l'actuel gouvernement
s'est attaqué aux républicains nous
proposons de revenir sur le principe de
l'écritement des allocations familiales
engagé par l'actuel gouvernement il doit
en être de même de la MAJ de la
majoration en fonction de l'âge lorsque
l'enfant att atteint 14 ans qui ne doit
pas être
écrité dans le même esprit la mise sous
condition de ressources des aides à la
garde conduit à exclure les familles les
plus aisées d'un d'un avantage par
rapport aux familles sans enfants aussi
nous proposons de supprimer les aides
sous conditions de ressources pour la
garde d'enfant dans un souci
d'universalité des prestations
familiales en outre le plafonnement à
niveau très bas du cotient familial
conduit à assujettir à l'impôt sur le
revenu les familles avec enfants dans
des proportions presque égales à celles
sans enfants de la même manière que les
familles riches doivent évidemment
contribuer davantage que les familles
pauvres à l'impôt sur le revenu et bien
le principe de contribution en fonction
des moyens conduit à davantage taxer les
familles sans enfants que les familles
av avec
enfant d'autres d'autres propositions
déplafonner le cootient familial je ne
je ne développerai pas parce que Claude
me dit que je dois activer un petit peu
je suis passionnée par le sujet donc
vous comprendrez que je suis voilà je je
mais nous allons parler entièrement de
la famille à l'instant merci Catherine
donc nous allons également proposer de
maintenir au niveau du foyer le cootient
conjugal de part et le le cootient
familial concernant la garde d'enfants
pour la multiplicité des aides publiques
qui qui conduit à une véritable gabg
nous proposons de remplacer les aides
existantes par une contribution unique
je vais vite Claude hein et ensuite et
enfin pour les en ce qui concerne juste
un petit mot les indépendants très très
important les indépendants aujourd'hui
sont exclus du Crédit Impôt famille ce
qui crée effectivement une distorsion il
y aurait quelques milliers de places qui
pourraient être financées euh direct par
donc ce qu'on propose c'est de légiférer
concernant la question du si F pour les
indépendants pour lever effectivement le
la dépense
plafonnée dernière dernière phrase cl
dernière phrase donc dernier élément
réduire les charges sur les salaires des
emplois à domicile pour relancer les
emplois familiaux je vous
[Applaudissements]
remerci rice du ha rein mais également
délégué général à la famille nous allons
maintenant donc aussi au côté de
Catherine parler de la famille et dans
la famille nous sommes nombreux bien sûr
que il faudra aussi penser à celles et
ceux qui ont besoin d'ê accompagner
celles qui deviendront un jour
dépendantes celles et ceux qui ont
besoin aussi de toute notre attention je
veux parler bien sûr des personnes
handicapées et puis de la jeunesse qui
aujourd'hui est confronté à plusieurs
difficultés et en particulier la
consommation de drogue et de pratique
addictive voilà la jeunesse les
personnes un peu plus vieillissantes et
celles et ceux qui ont toute notre
attention c'est la raison pour laquelle
je demande la présence sur cette tribune
de Valérie Debord de Denis Jaca de
Sophie goguin de Marianne montchan de
Christelle Prado et de Daniel Fasquel
mais nous serons également accompagnés
d'anès
even si agès est là peut-être pas encore
elle va pas tarder en tout cas c'est
elle qui va nous parler de la jeunesse
avant de parler de la jeunesse il faut
aussi parler de de de ce que nous serons
peut-être demain en tout cas de de
celles et ceux que dont nous nous
occupons aujourd'hui et qu'il qui sont
aujourd'hui dépendants alors il faut
plus que jamais améliorer la prise en
charge des personnes dépendantes car
plus de 80 % des français craignent pour
eux-mêmes c'est ce que je vous disis à
l'instant et pour leur parents mais à
laquelle seulement 3 % se préparent en
s'assurant alors il il faut partir il me
semble nécessaire de partir des besoins
évolutifs des personnes vivre plus
longtemps dignement dans notre domicile
alors on a beaucoup de solutions mais il
y a pour celles et ceux qui doivent
dépenser un coup moyen de 2200 € une
aide qu'on appelle la pas mais qui n'est
pas suffisante et c'est pour cela qu'il
faut aujourd'hui prendre conscience de
ce que tout doit être fait c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé à
Valérie de Bor qui elle est
vice-présidente de la région Grand Est
porte-parole des républicains mais qui à
la mairie s'occupe de la cohésion
sociale des seniors voilà pourquoi je
souhaiterais que tu interviennes sur
comment faire en sorte que nous
puissions prévo prévoir l'avenir est-ce
que l'on doit compter uniquement sur
notre société sur la participation où
est-ce que nous devons agir pour
l'avenir
personnellement merci cher Claude
mesdames et messieurs bonjour peut-être
juste un un chiffre pour fixer les
choses euh en 2035 c'est demain euh 12
millions de Français auront plus de 75
ans 1/3 plus de 60
ans on voit qu'aujourd'hui on le sait il
des médecins dans la salle les
problématiques de dépendance commencent
à survenir alors pas forcément au non
mais commencent à survenir à partir de
85 ans les Français d'un point de vue
familial utilise débloque tous les ans 7
milliards d'euros
à titre personnel pour accompagner dans
cas de ce qu'on appelle les aidans leurs
personnes âgées dépendantes on a
actuellement 1,4 million de personnes
qui bénéficient de laallocation
personnalisée d'autonomie à peu près
400000 en établissement les fameux
établissement d'épergement pour
personnes agâés dépendantes et 700000 à
domicile comme l'a très justement dit
Claude il y a un reste à charge
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que est payé la
part santé la part soins par à la fois
le Conseil départemental et l'Agence
Régionale de Santé via l'argent de
l'État il reste pour les familles en
moyenne en fonction de l'endroit où vous
habitez il est bien évident que sur
Paris et et sa grande couronne c'est
beaucoup plus cher que annonc chez moi
ou ou à mes ou ou ou chez d'autres il
reste en moyenne entre 1800 et 2200 €
par mois à charge des personnes pour les
gens qui ont des revenus extrêmement
faibles qui sont au min climat sociaux
c'est pris en charge par la solidarité
c'est fort heureux évidemment après
toute la classe moyenne et c'est une
classe moyenne vous voyez bien vu la
moyenne des retraites en France aux
alentours de 1200 € on voit que c'est
une charge extrêmement importante la
durée de vie en établissement est aux
alentours de 18 mois donc on voit que
c'est une charge extrêmement importante
à supporter pour les familles de
nombreux pays ont réfléchi à la façon de
trouver des solutions il nous apparaît
nous que à côté de la solidarité
nationale essentielle sur laquelle nous
souhaitons extrêmement insister chez les
républicains aujourd'hui il faut
préparer l'avenir l'avenir effectivement
avec la la durée de vie avec la qualité
des soins qui augmente avec l'industrie
qui va nous trouver des solutions
médicales complémentaires et nouvelles
l'avenir c'est effectivement de préparer
son vieillissement alors Claude l'a dit
un certain nombre de personnes mettent
déjà en place des dispositifs
acquierèent des dispositifs d'assurance
complémentaire d'assurance dépendance il
nous apparaît nous aujourd'hui qu'il
faut réfléchir à un dispositif global
avec un accompagnement un accompagnement
avec un bout de de défiscalisation afin
de permettre aux gens qui sont
conscieneux aux gens qui préparent leur
avenir aux gens qui sont effectivement
dans une dynamique positive la dynamique
des valeurs qui sont les nôtres
c'est-à-dire les gens qui ne se disent
pas je laisse aux autres la façon de
pourvoir à mes besoins mais en
responsabilité et en faisant en sorte
que mes enfants puissent avoir leur part
d'héritage je prépare mon avenir ben il
nous semble normal que nous
accompagnonss ces personnes avec
effectivement une défiscalisation donc
une des solutions que nous proposons
dans le cadre du projet c'est
effectivement une assurance avec une
incitation fiscale qui sera à côté de ce
qui existe actuellement et qui permettra
petit à petit et bien de prendre en
charge cette difficulté c'est aussi une
chance et je terminerai là-dessus
n'oublions pas que nous souhaitons tous
vieillir le plus longtemps possible en
meilleure santé possible et que les
moyens de la santé aujourd'hui vont nous
le permettre de plus en plus merci
Valérie merci Madame Debord et oui donc
penser à l'avenir mais aussi s'occuper
du présent et nous constatons
aujourd'hui que parce que ce
gouvernement n'a pas suffisamment pensé
au présent nous avons de nombreux
parents qui ont de des des journées
d'hospitalisation qui importantes alors
alors qu'il pourrait être accompagné
dans des des autres services des épad
des maisons d'accueil peu importe bref
faire en sorte que nos parents soi mieux
accompagnés alors pour cela il y a ces
ces possibilités là de ces accueils il y
a d'autres moyens technologique plus
important aujourd'hui et deny Jaca va
nous en parler il y a d'autres projets
comme permettre à celles et ceux qui
accompagnent les personnes dépendantes
d'avoir des des solutions de répie
pouvoir un peu de temps en temps
sortir du milieu dans lequel ils sont
bien sûr nécessaires mais pouvoir
prendre un petit peu j'allais dire
d'oxygène pour être encore plus aimant
et et écouter davantage celles et ceux
dont on a besoin d'accompagner voilà
pourquoi den Jaca va intervenir je
voudrais simplement et rapidement vous
présenter celui que beaucoup connaissent
ici Denis Jaca député de de de
laamoselle qui s'est beaucoup occupé des
seniors et et des personnes dépendantes
voilà pourquoi nous sommes heureux de
l'accueillir dans cette table ronde
merci merci Claude merci bonjour tout le
monde simplement en complément de ce que
vient de dire Valérie parce qu'on a
travaillé ensemble pendant de nombreuses
années à l'Assemblée nationale à ce
propos je tiens dire que dans le cadre
des républicains nous continuons à
travailler et c'est moi-même qui suis à
l'Assemblée nationale le président du
groupe d'étude sur les enjeux du
vieillissement alors Valérie vient de le
dire à l'instant ce problème d'une
cotisation spécifique il faut qu'on
avance on en parle depuis 1986 du temps
où Adrien Zeller était à l'époque
ministre des Affaires sociales et il
avait chargé d'ailleurs un autre
alsacien thob Brown de se pencher sur le
problème des personnes âgées dépendantes
il faut reconnaître que depuis çaa a peu
avancé et qu'il y a un problème de fond
Bernard accer connaît parfaitement le
problème parce que à l'époque on était
UDF d'un côté RPR de l'autre côté mais
on avait la même pensée il faut
s'occuper des personnes qui sont
vieillissantes dans notre pays alors
dans les sujets qui sont apparus ces
derniers temps qui étaient moins à la
mode et qui sont devenus à la mode mais
qui sont indispensables il y a comme
vient de le dire Claude à l'instant le
soutien donc aux aidans les solutions de
répi avant on avait beaucoup d'aidents
qui étaient plutôt des aidents familiaux
maintenant on a des aidents
professionnels mais il s'avère que pour
des raisons de coût c'est très souvent
un mélange des deux qui est autour de la
personne qui a besoin d'être aidé et que
se pose pour ces deux types d'idents des
solutions de répi et indirectement des
soutiens à ces aidents c'est-à-dire
qu'ils doivent être formés qu'ils soient
professionnel ou qu'il soi qu'il soi
familiaux deuxièmement il y a le
problème de ce qu'on appelle des métiers
de la prise en charge des personnes âgé
qu'elles soient dépendante ou pas
dépendante pendant un certain nombre
d'années en particulier du temps de la
NPE maintenant Pôle emploi il y avait
rien de plus désagréable de voir des
gens qui venaient nous voir en disant
bah écoutez à Pôle Emploi on nous a dit
allez voir votre député il vous trouvera
du travail il y en a plein auprès des
personnes âgées ce n'est pas évident car
il faut chez ces personn même s'il y a
de la bonne volonté une formation
minimale je dirais initiale minimale et
puis ensuite donc il faut une formation
continue tout le monde ne peut pas faire
ce type de travail surtout dans le cadre
professionnel ce qui est apparu et ce
qui est très important et au niveau
national nous avons euu madame le
professeur François set qui s'est penché
là-dessus c'est adapter toutes les
nouvelles technologies aux personnes
âgées aux personnes âgées dépendantes ou
aux personnes âgées qui se situent entre
un Girin et un et un GIR 6 de nombreuses
réflexions des cololloques des congrès
ont eu lieu à l'Assemblée nationale je
vais pas revenir dessus mais c'est tout
ce qui tourne autour de la domotique et
là je veux qu'on parle je fais une
passerelle avec la dans je dirais le
sujet de la Table Ronde après il faut
qu'on parle de personnes en perte
d'autonomie personnees âgées personne
handicapé car les nouvelles technologies
peuvent s'appliquer aux deux catégories
de personnes et puis enfin c'est un
autre grand sujet on parle toujours de
prévention on n'est quand même pas très
bon dans notre pays concernant la
prévention il est évident que si on
avait une politique de prévention dans
le cadre de la santé il y aurait je
dirais des personnes âgé dépendantes une
a toujours ou en perd d'autonomie mais
cela interviendrait plus tardivement
alors on avait demandé à la ministre Mar
Touren en son temps qui est une loi de
santé publique on a eu une loi de santé
on nous a dit publique au départ mais
avec une toute petite part de santé
publique et avir une plus petite part de
prévention et indirectement tout le
monde le sait fort bien que si il y a
une bonne politique de prévention bien
on évitera des journées
d'hospitalisation qui ont un coût voilà
donc les quelques mots que je voulais
vous
dire merci Denis oui ces journées
d'hospitalisation c'est plus de 2
milliards bien sûr on peut voir le côté
financier important on en a parlé tout à
l'heure la dette sociale existe je crois
qu'il faut aussi aborder ce sujet sur le
plan humain je vous le disais tout à
l'heure nous sommes tous concernés de
près ou de loin par par ce sujet parce
que nous avons la chance de vivre plus
longtemps nous avons aussi des des des
moyens des des traitements qui nous
permettent de de vivre dans de
meilleures conditions mais nous devons
pouvoir assumer cette dépendance qui qui
malheureusement génère une une forme
d'inquiétude
surrajouté je parle d'une inquiétude des
Français surrajouté à l'inquiétude
sociale de l'emploi de
l'économie de l'insécurité tout cela
tout cela n'apporte pas une quiétude et
je crois que nous sommes en devoir
d'apporter cette quiétude alors il y a
aussi d'autres personnes dont il faut
s'occuper de la façon la plus importante
je veux bien sûr parler des personnes
handicapées et concernant le handicap il
y a des choses aussi qu'il faut dire on
n'a pas toujours été que parfait mais
nous avons et notre mouvement peut-être
fier d'avoir été à l'origine de grandes
réformes en faveur des des personnes
handicapées de je dois rappeler quand
même les la la réforme de 75 celle de
2005 celle que nous Allion mettre en en
route ensuite et qui malheureusement n'a
pas été pris sous le même sous le même
angle par ce gouvernement et je suis
très heureuse d'accueillir à nos côtés
et et vous tous aussi je voudrais
accueillir Christelle Prado qui est
présidente de la que je donneis bien
exactement présidente de l'Union
nationale des associations de parents de
personnes handicapées mental ce nom que
l'on connaît bien l'un pays vous faites
beaucoup pour nos enfants et et qu'ils
soient jeune ou vieillissant nous avons
la même préoccupation et vous y
travaillez au quotidien et je sais que
vous avez aussi abordé ce sujet-là au
cours de la Convention des Nations Unies
relatives au droits des personnes
handicapées je crois que il serait
intéressant que vous expliquiez à cette
belle assemblée au républicains ce qui
en est ressorti et votre travail au
quotidien pour améliorer la qualité de
vie de nos enfants et de nos grands
enfants Christelle Prado je vous cède la
parole je vous remerci et vous avez bien
fait de rappeler qu'effectivement nous
sommes des parents des parents engagés
et ce n'est pas le handicap de nos
enfants qui nous pose un problème c'est
l'exclusion sociale qu'il
génère pour la vie de notre enfant et
pour la vie de la famille toute entière
je voudrais faire le lien avec ce que
vient de dire Denis Jaca je pense que
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire dans
cette salle que le vieillissement n'est
pas un problème ou sinon nous serions
tous porteurs d'un d'un grave problème
et moi j'y viens rapidement maintenant
le vieillissement devient un problème
quand nous présentons une incapacité ou
quand nous devenons en situation de
handicap donc il y a des points de
convergence à travailler je vais pas
m'étendre dessus ça sera tout le travail
que vous aurez à mener mais concernant
l'accessibilité les aides techniques les
aides humaines le répi pour les aidanss
enfin voilà beaucoup de beaucoup de
pistes de recherche je voudrais rappeler
les résultats d'une enquête handicap
incapacité dépendance mené par l'INC en
2003 qui met en lumière que un français
sur qu présente des incapacités ce n'est
donc pas un épiphénomène voilà hein
c'est important de connaître pour
pouvoir les traiter de connaître les
volumes et avant de vous faire un un
certain nombre de propositions j'ai
envie qu'on partage ensemble une vision
de la problématique parce que euh en
France cette vision partagée elle est
très récente elle date grâce au portage
politique du président shirac de la loi
du 11 février 2005 je voudrais d'abord
vous faire une citation euh de Darwin
parce que euh elle me semble
intéressante c'est grande et notre faute
si la misère de nos pauvres découle non
pas des lois naturelles mais de nos
institution et en France aujourd'hui
c'est bien le cas même si la loi de 2005
a voulu corriger un certain nombre de
choses grâce à cette loi la France a
rejoint le cortège des nations qui
considère
qu'effectivement la situation de
handicap n'est pas un problème médical
hein c'est la pathologie qui est un
problème médical cette patholog elle
peut générer des déficiences et le
handicap n'est que la conséquence
sociale de ce dont la personne est
porteuse donc elle a deux axes
directeurs que sont l'accessibilité et
la compensation des conséquences du
handicap euh et aujourd'hui on a tout
faux hein plus de 10 ans après on a tout
faux parce que on a commencé par dire on
va mettre en place un dispositif qui
s'appelle euh la prestation de
compensation du handicap et puis on
s'est dit ça coûte cher forcément parce
qu'on a négligé l'aspect de la
compensation collective qui était
l'accessibilité à tout pour tous donc en
faisant les choses à l'envers ça coûte
cher mais c'est
normal en 2010 la France est engagée
donc par la ratification de la
Convention internationale des personnes
handicapées sur six principes directeurs
euh celui notamment de la liberté de
choix euh je ne reviens je ne vais pas
beaucoup développer d'abord parce que
j'en ai pas le temps mais euh vous le
savez et en tant que responsable
politique vous y êtes en encore plus
sensible beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne
nous comprennent plus et pas simplement
les personnes déficientes
intellectuelles parce que nous utilisons
des niveaux de langage qui sont
beaucoupin beaucoup trop élevés parce
que à force de circonvolution et de
périphrase pour ne pas dire qu'un chat
s'appelle un chat voilà on arrive à
masquer la problématique et à ne pas
laisser aux citoyens le pouvoir d'agir
donc d'abord la liberté de choix par un
accès à l'information le principe de non
disccrimination
il faut que vous sachiez moi je voudrais
je vais vous juste poser une petite
question dans cette salle qui a passé un
examen médical avant d'avoir sa carte
d'lecteur personne et bien les personnes
handicapées si voilà une vraie
discrimination dans notre pays le
troisème principe c'est la priorité au
droit commun et NOTAM alors toutes
toutes les toutes les structures de
droits commun le 4è point c'est le
respect de la différence j'ai entendu
une personne
handicapée dans dans une commune qu'on
connaît bien toutes les deux hein
puisqu'on est du même du même coin si je
puis dire à Falaise dire moi quand je
montais dans le bus je montais pas tout
seul je montais avec ma peur ça a du
sens il faut que ça ça s'arrête et puis
l'égalité des chances et et on a parler
tout à l'heure de de l'accès aux soins
c'est quelque chose de fondamental vous
me regardez je suis pas une personne
démunie on est bien d'accord là-dessus
et bien ça fait 1 an que j'essaie de
faire soigner les dents de ma fille 1 an
et elle
souffre et il y a des millions de
personnes comme ça voilà donc la réalité
de l'accès aux soins c'est ça alors rien
de rien de révolutionnaire dans les
principe de cette convention mais
pourtant la construction de ces 40
dernières années a enfermé excusez-moi
les personnes euh handicapé dans un
statut qui les prive euh de la
jouissance du patrimoine national commun
hein on a fait quelque chose de bien
mais en même temps les a enfermé alors
tout ceci en ce moment et c'est ça qui
est inquiétant est renforcé par des
dérives biodétermin ministe alors je
vous renvoie à l'ouvrage de Stepan Gould
sur la mal mesure de l'homme qui vise à
à justifier biologiquement les
différences social je cite simplement
une dernière expertise
euh sur le handicap hein paru en 2016
qui dit le contexte socio-économique
incluant revenu et niveau d'éducation
des parents joue un rôle certain sur la
prévalence de la déficience
intellectuelle légère comment peut-on
écrire encore des choses comme ça
aujourd'hui et et c'est là où le combat
de l'UNAP rejoint celui d'ATD car monde
enfin enfin très clairement toute façon
on est de la le même sang qui coule dans
les veines avec ATD donc le combat d'ATD
nous rejoint ce que veut l'unapi
maintenant puisqu'on a bien compris la
problématique et on l'a partagé ensemble
c'est plusieurs choses d'abord une
priorité au droit commun ne partons pas
de système ségrégatif une priorité au
droit commun et les 94000 professionnels
que les associations de l'UNAP embour
gauche sont là tout simplement pour
venir renforcer les structures de droit
commun qui n'ont pas bénéficié de
formation qui leur permettent de
comprendre ce qu'est la singularité
d'une personne en situation de handicap
et puis trois vœux le premier c'est
d'abord connaître autour de la
connaissance aujourd'hui uniquement 30 %
des personnes qui sont accueillies dans
des établissements et services ont un
diagnostic comment peut-on accompagner
des personnes dont on ne connaît pas le
diagnostic mais je veux dire on fait
n'importe quoi on va donner de
l'ortophonie préconiser de l'orophonie à
une personne qui ne pourra jamais avoir
accès à la parole au lieu de mettre en
en place des moyens substitutifs de
communication on na pas d'évaluation des
besoins l'UNAP il l'a fait 47000
personnes sans solution en France en
octobre 2015 Nicolas Sarkozi avait mis
en avant un plan de création de 50000
places en 2008 qui devait être exécuté
en 5 ou 6 ans aujourd'hui il n'est
toujours pas exécuté hein voilà et 47000
personnes sur le carreau ce qu'il nous
faut c'est former les professionnels et
là je reviens à une préconisation du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental je vous renvoie ces
travaux parce que pour tous les sujets
qu'on vient de traiter ce matin il y a
eu dans l'ancienne mandature des écrits
qui vous permettront d'avancer cette
préconisation c'est celle de créer un
groupe national formation handicap qui
comprennent les organismes de formation
les partenaires sociaux et les
associations représent tentative pour
auditionner l'ensemble des champs
professionnels recueillir les pratiques
existantes et capter les besoins en
formation avec ça on élabore une matrice
sur les fondamentaux professionnels pour
une meilleure collaboration
interprofessionnelle et on décline en
arborescence par branche et professions
enfin
euh il faut à tout prix que nous nous
mettions en en route pour rendre
effectif tous les droits aujourd'hui il
y a une organisation de la pén il y a
une organisation du non recours au droit
alors il faut pour reprendre les propos
très intéressants de beaucoup de
personnes qui sont intervenues de depuis
ce matin il faut vraiment un
développement d'une stratégie
d'investissement social et de prévention
c'est-à-dire une politique
d'anticipation et pas une politique de
réparation je termine le contrat social
passé en 45 honnêtement il a vécu enfin
j'espère qu'on est tous d'accord
là-dessus les risques ont évolué mais le
problème c'est que le traitement que
nous queord nous faisons à ces nouveaux
risques n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux alors ayons le courage de
véritable politiqu inclusivees euh et en
tant que maire et que citoyen je
conclurai par nos enfants coûteront cher
à la société tant qu'ils n'auront pas de
valeur à ses yeux retenez ça je pense
que c'est important merci merci
Christelle Prado merci pour vos propos
et et je vois la chance que nous avons
dans cette convention c'est la
complémentarité de ces table rondes et
on voit bien que dans le domaine de la
santé les profess professionnel
aujourd'hui sont en demande de formation
mais également de formation pour pouvoir
soigner les personnes handicapées non
pas par rapport à leur handicap mais
tout simplement parce que il y a une
communication qui doit exister et que
cette communication pouvoir être
approfondie donc mieux appréhendé parler
clairement du handicap c'est-à-dire
parler simplement du handicap il pourra
de ce fait être beaucoup plus appréhendé
par la population en général et on on
verra de moins en moins cette
ségrégation auquelle vous faites
référence mais nous avons beaucoup
réfléchi à cela aux républicains je
remercie au passage toute l'équipe qui
travaill à mes côté sur les les sujets
sociétaux nous avons beaucoup travaillé
sur ces sujets et et nous voulons
renforcer l'accès au numérique pour les
personnes handicapées nous voulons
expliquer ce qu'est la charte Romain
Jacob et je vais demander à Marianne
monchand d'intervenir parce que tout
cela ce sont évidemment des sujet qui ne
nous parlent pas forcément mais qui
doivent demain nous parler et c'est pour
cela que Marianne monchand qui
aujourd'hui à la à la mission de
secrétaire nationale à la protection
sociale mais qui est une de mes
anciennes collègues puisque nous avons
été ensemble députés et ensemble
secrétaire d'État tu l'étais pour les
personnes handicapées voilà je te cède
la parole pour compléter ou apporter un
plus aux éléments de de Christel Prado à
qui j'aurais encore un grand merci
d'être venu pour nous parler de nos
enfants et qu'il soi jeune ou plus grand
ou
vieillissant merci beaucoup Claude merci
et oui en effet je crois qu'on peut tout
à fait applaudir et Claude et et
Christel Prado merci pour cette table
ronde merci aussi pour ce ce ce
complément de perspective qui nous est
offert ce matin au sein des républicains
plus plusieurs choses me viennent à
l'esprit à la suite des diverses
interventions et et cell de Christel
Prado la première intervention c'est que
en effet je pense qu'il est important de
rappeler que dans notre famille
politique il y a une très forte
tradition d'investissement sur la
politique du handicap Christelle vous
avez bien voulu rappeler l'action du
président Chirak elle s'est poursuivie
et l'engagement de Nicolas Sarko sur
l'augmentation de la hache je crois que
nous ne pouvons pas l'oublier c'était un
véritable projet que d'augmenter la
hache de 25 % je veux rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
socialiste a ramené cette augmentation à
01 % si je ne me trompe pas ça doit
faire quelque chose comme 7 € par mois
de plus ce n'est pas cela une politique
ambitieuse en matière de handicap pour
notre pays je veux
je je veux redire je veux redire que
l'Esprit des lois que nous avons portter
au sein de la famille politique se fonda
sur des principes à la fois simples mais
redoutables le premier principe c'est
celui d'affirmer la pleine citoyenneté
de nos compatriotes en situation de
handicap la citoyenneté quand on est en
situation de handicap ça n'est pas une
option c'est un droit premier c'est
celui i qui affirme notre
fraternité chaque fois que l'on revient
sur ce principe là c'est notre société
toute entière qui régresse et ne nous y
trompons pas dans les angoisses
actuelles de nos compatriotes dans ce
sentiment de mal vivre dans ce sentiment
d'avenir diffus et angoissant qui
étraint beaucoup d'entre nous il y a
cette idée qui tarude les Français qu'à
vrai dire on ne sait pas très bien si se
vivre ensemble
sera tenue si cette
promesse cette promesse de citoyenneté
sera honorée et je pense que cela
participe de la fragilisation de toute
notre société qui on l'a rappelé Claude
et Denis l'explique bien Valérie la fait
est en phase d'un vieillissement
extrêmement prononcé c'est une chance
mais c'est un défi le handicap ça n'est
pas un sujet du passé c'est un sujet de
l'avenir il change change de forme il
change de visage les très grands
prématurés des accidents sévères les
pathologies chronique dont on a si
longtemps parlé ce matin elles ont des
conséquences sur notre capacité à vivre
libre à exprimer notre citoyenneté et la
perte de chance celle qui fait que dans
ce cadre- là on est privé d'emploi qu'on
ne participe pas comme un plein citoyen
à l'effort de la nation que l'on peine à
trouver sa place ce terme insupportable
c'est des girirac qui disait un Plou
vous savez cette espèce d'idée qu'il
fallait se jouer des coudes pour arriver
à être au monde c'est quelque chose qui
révolte les militants et les citoyens
que nous
sommes quand nous avons construit ces
textes de loi 75 mais j'ai le souvenir
plus précis de 2005 et ensuite des
travaux que nous avons fait ensemble
claud quand nous étions en effet au
gouvernement toi et moi nous l'avons
construit dans une forme de partenariat
social sur lequel j'aimerais bien qu'on
réfléchisse le partenariat social
aujourd'hui il est dans la rue sous des
formes qui nous angoissent des formes
qui sont violentes et qui à dire vrai ne
nous laissent présager rien de bon moi
j'ai une autre image du partenariat
social c'est celui des associations qui
dialoguent avec les partis politiques
des associations qui dialoguent avec les
parlementaires et des associations qui
participent de cette coproduction
législative qui nous permet de régénérer
notre projet de société je sais que le
président Sarkozi est sensible à cet
aspect des choses et j'appelle de mes
vœux que nous psions que nous puissions
poursuivre dans ce chemin et puis et
j'en terminerai par là Claude il va
falloir s'atteler mes chers amis à
quelques grands scandales il n'est pas
possible que
47500 personnes aujourd'hui parce
qu'elles sont en situation de handicap
n'est pas de solution pas de solution ça
veut dire quoi elles sont où elles sont
dans leur famille auprès de parents
parfois très âgés dans des situations
d'isolement caractérisé et qui sont ces
personnes quels sont leurs visages des
personnes avec des handicaps psychiques
lourds des personnes avec des
polyhandicap des personnes dont toute la
famille est
évidemment complètement j'allais dire
symbiotique parce que il est impossible
impossible d'imaginer une seconde que le
combat s'arrête je voulais le rappeler
parce que dans ces projets politiques
que nous portons et c'est notre fierté à
nous chez les républicains nous avons le
devoir de mettre des visages de mettre
des chiffres et de mettre un engagement
politique il s'agit de politique mes
chers amis de politique en face de ces
réalités voilà une modeste contribution
mais je je crois que c'est à la hauteur
des enjeux des années qui viennent bravo
merci Marianne vous voyez au
républicains nous essayons de trouver
les solutions pour que chacun d'entre
nous et particulièrement celles et ceux
qui qui en ont le plus besoin c'est
notre fraternité je la mets peut-être
pas en opposition mais presque par
rapport à la solidarité dont celles et
ceux qui aujourd'hui nous gouvernent
n'arrêteent pas de nous parler mais nous
n'avons pas la même vision de cette
solidarité c'est une vraie fraternité ce
message humain bien sûr qu'il est aussi
comptable mais il doit être avant tout
humain parce que nous avons besoin de
cette attention pour compléter les
propos de Marianne il y a aussi a des
difficultés sur l'accessibilité à
l'emploi sur l'accessibilité en général
plus particulièrement sur la formation
ce sont des des sujets qui intéressent
aussi Sophie gogin que je vous présente
Sophie alors est une une femme très
impliquée sur ces sujets et qui connaît
la réalité du quotidien puisqu'elle est
maire d'une commune qui s'appelle Dozulé
vous connaissez peut-être pas mais c'est
une très belle commune est conseillèr
régional de basseen dit secrétaire
national du handicap et et Sophie va
nous apporter son éclairage sur cette
nouvelle impulsion à la politique du
handicap que les républicains veulent
donner merci beaucoup Claude mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie pour votre
présence nombreuse parce que depuis ce
matin avec la qualité des échanges que
nous avons vous nous encouragez dans nos
choix et dans les orientations
politiques que nous prendrons dans les
semaines qui viennent et je voulais
remercier Claude de son investissement à
nos côtés pour permettre aujourd'hui que
nous ayons ces ces échanges alors Claude
tu l'as dit je suis s'il y a une bonne
nouvelle c'est que nous avons gagné la
région Normandie réunifiée et donc je
suis vice-présidente de la Région en
charge du développement économique et en
même temps maire élu local et je connais
bien madame Prado dans le Calvados ce
qui permet quand on est en charge du
développement économique et en même
temps nous avons l'expérience de terrain
de faire le lien sur ce qu'aujourd'hui
nous devons porter en terme de de messag
et d'évolution de notre regard sur le
handicap et c'est ce que souhaitent
porter les républicains avec chacune et
chacun d'entre vous dans une méthode de
coconstruction vous l'avez dit il faut
donner une nouvelle impulsion cette
nouvelle impulsion l'accessibilité doit
nous y conduire ensemble parce que
mesdames et messieurs pour les personnes
en situation de handicap l'accessibilité
ça n'est pas le nombre de mètres Carr ça
n'est pas forcément toujours la pente
plus difficile à franchir même si ce
sont des éléments de notre quotidien
auxquels les élus locaux contribuent et
s'investissent de plus en plus c'est
aussi l'accessibilité à la vie il s'agit
de cela l'accessibilité pour une
personne en situation de handicap et
pour celles et ceux qui l'entourent pour
sa famille c'est l'accessibilité à la
vie et au-delà de ça c'est chacune des
étapes qui conduisent à se construire et
quand on se construit et bien on
retrouve de la dignité et on se sent
citoyen à part entière et je crois que
la France a énormément à apporter dans
tout ce que nous avons on déjà réussi à
faire mais à encore être plus exemplaire
au niveau européen énormément de choses
bougent sur la prise en charge pardon
des personnes en situation de handicap
et nous devons franchir un pas
supplémentaire l'accessibilité c'est la
société plus inclusive celle que vous
invoquez madame la Présidente c'est
celle qui permet depuis l'école jusqu'à
la formation continue en passant par le
fait de pouvoir envisager un jour d'être
autonome dans sa vie et de gagner sa vie
c'est la situation du travail adapté et
moi je crois beaucoup et je sais
Marianne que tu t investi à ce que nous
pouvons travailler avec l'ensemble des
des entreprises sur la capacité d'une
personne en situation de handicap et
bien à travailler à gagner sa vie et du
coup à s'épanouir pleinement et le lien
avec le l'activité politique locale
parce que nous avons un engagement fort
aussi et des convictions et le fait que
nous ayons gagné des régions nous
permettent aussi d'avoir de nouveaux
leviers les compétences régionales
permettent largement sur le parcours
d'une vie d'une personne en situation de
handicap et bien sans que cela coûte
mais parce que nous avons un tissu de
bonnes pratiques et des réflexes et une
volonté politique et bien d'aider ça
passe par le soutien que nous pouvons
avoir dans les lycées les réflexions sur
le lycée du futur ça passe par l'offre
d'achat vous avez dit il faut parler
vrai et bien quand une région achète
parce qu'elle a la formation
professionnelle et l'apprentissage
autant de millions d'euros sur l'offre
d'achat elle peut infléchir la courbe en
permettant d'acheter des formations qui
soient accessibles dans les sens du
numérique mais aussi dans le sens
qu'elle va permettre d'accéder à un
emploi et donc nous avons aussi tout un
dialogue à construire avec les
collectivité territoriale les
passerelles entre les lycées Les Ulis
lescis et le fait que plus tard on peut
envisager d'avoir un parcours
universitaire j'ai rencontré énormément
de parents d'enfants qui disent moi mon
fils va passer le bac j'en suis fier
plus tard je vais je vais lui demander
ce qu'il va faire à l'université et
c'est ça qu'il faut que nous portions
c'est cette valeur positive de
l'accessibilité à la vie au travers
chacune de nos
responsabilités alors beaucoup de choses
ont déjà été dites le fait de sur
l'accessibilité que j'appelle matérielle
il faut être pragmatique et de trouver
des solutions adaptées sur des nouvelles
politiques de la ville ou d'aménagement
urbain je préfère 1000 fois des lieux
partagés comme j'essaie de le développer
dans ma ville où des enfants des écoles
viennent rencontrer les enfants euh de ù
les les résidents des zates sur des
projets partagés et en même temps
travailler sur de l'intergénérationnel
avec les personnes âgées qui sont à
proximité je préfère 1000 fois qu'on
réfléchisse en terme de lieux partagés
dans nos communes rurales mais aussi
dans nos villes plutôt que de réfléchir
en terme de normes je crois que nous
avons des objectifs ensemble à atteindre
et c'est ça aussi le projet de de
société sur l'accessibilité et puis je
dirai un mot parce que nous avons
beaucoup de choses à dire mais vous le
verrez dans les propositions qui sont
faites et je sais qu'avec mes collègues
nous sommes parfaitement convaincus vous
savez ce que femme Dieu veut Dieu le
veut et que vous avez là quand même vous
avez là quand même une une une une force
de volonté je je tiens à vous le dire
parce que pour avoir travaillé avec elle
dans d'autres parcours je sais qu'elles
ont ces convictions chevillé au corps
c'est l'accessibilité numérique il n'y a
pas eu un moment depuis ce matin où nous
n'avons pas évoquer l'avenir de la santé
et de la protection sociale sous l'angle
de numérique le numérique c'est une
obligation pour les politiques publiques
du futur et que ce sont les républicains
qui porteront je crois cettevolution
numérique dans l'ensemble des solutions
que nous serons capables d'apporter aux
habitants sur
l'accessibilité le numérique est un
numérique humaniste je crois qu'il est
tout à fait important de dire qu'il
apportera des solutions très concrètes
pour nos concitoyens et leur famill
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention merci sopie nous te faisons
confiance N faisons confiance au fanais
pour partager nos convictions nos
convictions qui nous amènne à parler
d'une d'une proportion importante de
personnes qui sont atteints par le
handicap je veux parler de l'autisme oui
parce que importante parce que 600000
personnes en France sont concernés et et
et en gros on peut estimer à une
naissance sur 100 d'une d'un enfant qui
peut-être atteint de l'autisme Daniel
Fasquel va intervenir sur ce sujet au
combien important et que veut prendre à
bras le encore les républicains Daniel
Fasquel est député du pastecalis il est
maire d'une magnifique commune qui
s'appelle toutqu plage Paris Plage
pardon toutqu Paris- plage et et et
Daniel est un un un un homme au-delà
d'être un député et d'être un maire
c'est un homme qui s'investit
véritablement pour aider les enfants qui
sont et les adultes après qui sont
atteints par ce handicap je te cède la
parole pour quelques minutes merci
merci merci beaucoup j'ai bien compris
qu'il fallait aller à
l'essentiel je dirais que un il faut une
prise une prise de conscience est
absolument nécessaire en matière
d'autisme c'était il y a 20 ans une
naissance sur 2000 c'est aujourd'hui une
naissance sur 100 c'est dire que nous
sommes tous concernés et dans certains
pays au Japon par exemple on a une
naissance sur 80 donc c'est un phénomène
nouveau il faut en avoir conscience
parents grands-parents nous pouvons dans
nos fam tous très un jour ou l'autre
être concernés deuxème point il y a sur
ce sujet un décalage énorme entre le
discours officiel et puis la réalité de
terrain la réalité que que vivent les
familles le discours officiel c'est par
exemple C Goolen nville qui nous disait
il y a quelques jours à l'occasion de la
Conférence nationale du handicap grand M
don les socialistes sont le secret qui a
eu lieu la semaine dernière lorsque nous
mettons en œuvre le plan autiste de 2013
2017 nous agissons pour que la France
rejoigne le concert des nations
exemplaires dans ce domaine bah je peux
vous assurer qu'il y a du chemin à faire
pour rejoindre le concert des nations
exemplaires dans ce domaine en 2014 44 %
44 % des personnes autistes étaient
victime de de maltraitance de mauvais
traitement ou de carence en matière de
soins et 80 % aujourd'hui en France 80 %
des enfants autistes sont exclus de
l'école et madame Neville nous dit
qu'elle va une réponse que je lui posé à
l'Assemblée nationale au question
d'actualité il y a 3 semaines nous dit
qu'elle va régler tous les problèmes en
créant 700 places supplémentaires en
unité d'enseignement en maternel alors
qu'il y a 8000 naissances par an 700
places 8000 naissance par an il y a donc
un décalage considérable entre le
discours officiel et la réalité ce que
l'on peut constater aussi nous avons en
la matière un bilan dans de nombreux
domaines vous l'avez mis en avant depuis
ce matin mais dans ce domaine également
il y a évidemment la loi de 2005 a le
travail du député chaussi il y a surtout
le deuxième plan autisme qui a été porté
par Nicolas Sarkozi et par le
gouvernement qui qui qui l'entourait un
deuxième plan autisme qui était très
courageux puisque grâce notamment à ce
deuxème plan autisme le diagnostic a été
posé clairement l'autisme ça n'est pas
une psychose c'est un handicap et puis
nous avons eu la chance d'avoir en mars
2012 cétait la conséquence d'un long
chemin des recommandations la Autorité
de santé qui ont été très clair très
clair et qui ont recommandé les méthodes
éducatives et comportementales et posé
définitivement le bon diagnostic en ce
qui concerne l'autisme le problème c'est
que depuis 2012 alors qu'il fallait
mettre en œuvre ces recommandations il
s'est quasiment rien passé le troème
plan autisme c'est un échec total et sur
le terrain les familles sont désespéré
alors comment mettre fin à ce scandale
français parce qu'il y a en la matière
un véritable scandal français tant notre
pays a pris du retard par rapport aux
autres pays en Europe et partout dans le
monde 1 il faut absolument améliorer le
dépistage c'est une une urgence
absolue tout sachant que 70 écoutez bien
ce chiffre 70 % des enfants autistes S
sont dépistés très tôt entre 18 mois et
et 3 ans 70 % des enfants autistes
peuvent avoir atteint à l'âge de 7 ans
un niveau de langage fonctionnel c'est
c'est un chiffre qu'il faut bien avoir
en tête or en France on a encore
beaucoup trop de retard et on dépiste
encore beaucoup trop tard l'autisme 2 ne
plus exclure les enfants autistes de
l'école en en Italie 100 % en France 20
% des enfants autistes sont scolarisés
en Italie c'est 100 % des enfants
autistes qui sont scolarisés et la
France la Suède a fait le même choix 100
% des enfantistes qui sont scolarisés et
elle interdit les institutions
spécialisées en
1995 3IS interdire la psychanalyse
définitivement dans le traitement de
l'autisme et réorienter toutes les
formations et tous les financements en
faveur des seules méthodes qui sont
efficaces et scientifiquement reconnu
qui sont les méthodes éducatives et
comportementales quatre mettre fin à
toutes les maltraitances euh le comité
des enfants de l'ONU en février de cette
année a à nouveau dénoncé la France pour
maltraitance à l'égard des autistes en
particulier en mettant fin au packing
j'ai déposé une proposition loi euh je
remercie euh mes collègues nombreux
l'avoir Cigné puisque cette méthode
malheureusement et malgré ce qui a été
dit en 2012 continue d'être pratiqué en
France et puis enfin mettre le paquet
sur la recherche parce que il faut à
tout prix essayer de mieux comprendre
quelles sont les les causes de de
l'autisme pour mieux s'attaquer à ce
problème puis un dernier point qui
concerne le financement parce que on me
dit toujours oui mais tout cela va
coûter très cher mais en fait un si on
réoriente les moyens qui sont mal
affectés vers les mauvaises méthodes
vers les bonnes méthodes déjà on va
régler une grande partie du problème
sans que ça coûte un centime de plus
puis surtout il y a évidemment un drame
humain mais c'est un drame également
financier il faut savoir que si on prend
en charge convenablement les enfants
autistes pendant 10 ans 30000 € par an
pour 300000 € on sauve plus d'un enfant
sur
de qui deviendra un adulte qui pourra
s'insérer convenablement dans la vie
alors que en ne faisant pas cet effort
de dépistage et de prise en char des
enfants autistes et bien on fait ce que
l'on fait aujourd'hui 60 % des
hospitalisations dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques ce sont des autistes on
les accape de médicaments on les enferme
on les maltraite et il faut savoir que
en agissant de la sorte ça coûte pour
chaque personne qu'on n pas été capable
de soigner et qu'on maltraite entre 5 et
8 millions d'euros donc on fera y
compris financièrement de sacrés
économies en prenant enfin à brasore ce
problème alors oui si on veut que la
France rejoigne le concer des nations
exemplaires dans ce domaine il faut que
que les républicains reviennent au
pouvoir en 2017 et qu'on mette en œuvre
ses propositions merci
bravo et c'est le trésorier des
républicain qui vous parle et et et mais
merci d'avoir eu cette approche bien sûr
financière mais surtout humaine je je
crois que c'est le maître mot avoir
cette attention pour chacun d'entre nous
merci pour ton intervention Daniel alors
nous nous ici au républicains nous
n'avons pas fait de grands effets de
manche pour la jeunesse parce que c'est
ce qui s'est malheureusement passé avec
celles ceux qui sont au pouvoir
aujourd'hui nous nous en occupons de la
jeunesse et je suis ravie après les
propos de Sophie gguin vice-présidente
du conseil régional que un autre conseil
régional s'occupe aussi de de la
jeunesse sous différents aspects en
particulier c'est tout à fait nouveau
concernant les la consommation des
drogues et des pratiques addictives chez
les jeunes bien sûr je vous présente
agès éren qui est conseillère
régionale de Paris hein voilà et qui de
oui de l'île-defance France
pardonnez-moi ah oui de
l'île-de-fance agès pardon vous me
perturbez agès va vous parler de ce que
le conseil régional a mis en place il
faut juste rappeler que 10 % des
adolescents franciliens fument plus d'un
joint par jour c'est un chiffre qui a
doublé en 3 ans hein il était temps
qu'on arrive il était temps que Valérie
pcrè arrive à la région île-de-fance la
consommation de cannabis est une cause
massive de dégrageage scolaire donc de
démotivation donc aussi de trouble et de
concentration au milieu scolaire et et
finalement d'échecs scolair agès peux-tu
nous dire ce que vous avez fait en
région île-de-fance avec plaisir merci
merci Claude alors voilà donc pour ceux
qui ne me connaissent pas je suis donc
agè Evren je suis vice-présidente de la
Région Île-de-France en charge de
l'éducation et de la culture Valérie
pcrè donc a regroupé les deux
délégations parce que nous partons du
principe que l'éducation passe par la
culture et vice-versa et en effet Claude
tu l'as dit notre fil rouge d'abord et
avant tout parce qu'on a été extrêmement
caricaturé sur ce sujet qui est
extrêmement important et sur lequel
malheureusement la gauche ne sait
absolument pas positionné ou en tout cas
est resté totalement inactive et les les
chiffres pardon sont très révélateurs
d'un échec en la matière notre fil rouge
à la région avec Valérie pcrè c'est
d'abord de lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire il faut savoir qu'on a chaque
année 30000 jeunes qui décroche du
système éducatif c'est-à-dire qui quitte
le système éducatif avant même
l'obtention d'un diplôme et on sait que
les non diplômés malheureusement sont
les premiers à être surexposés au
chômage donc c'est sur cela qu'on doit
travailler particulièrement les causes
du décrochage sont évidemment
multifactorielles il y a des raisons
personnelles il y a des raisons sociales
il y a parfois une orientation subie et
donc non choisi qui par définition
débouche sur de la démotivation et du
décrochage scolaire mais il y a aussi et
c'est très important de le rappeler le
les addictions alors les addictions il
n'y a pas seulement le cannabis il y a
aussi les drogues hein par parce qu'on a
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 17 ans 89 % de
nos jeunes qui consomment de l'alcool 89
% et tu l'as dit Claude on a 10 % des
jeunes franciliens qui ont fumé qui
fument plus d'un joint par jour 10 % ce
chiffre a doublé entre 2013 et
aujourd'hui alors face à ce défi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on reste les bras
croisés en se disant ça ne nous regarde
pas on fait comme le fait François
Hollande qui est complètement
indifférence à notre indifférente pardon
à notre jeunèe nous c'est tout l'inverse
alors on est et ça c'est important de le
préciser parce qu'encore une fois nous
avons été caricaturés nous ne sommes que
sur de la prévention il n'est pas
question pour nous d'accuser ni de
stigmatiser les jeunes tout au contraire
moi je vais beaucoup dans les lycées je
rencontre énormément de proviseurs que
me disent les proviseur premièrement ils
me disent ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que c'est un phénomène contagieux
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des noyaux
solidaires on a des groupes d'élèves et
que si certains élèves veulent faire
partie du groupe et être acceptés ils
sont obligés de fumer sinon ils ne font
pas partie du groupe et donc quand qu un
élève est vulnérable évidemment pour
faire partie du groupe il est obligé de
se mettre à fumer première chose
deuxième chose ils me disent on voit des
élèves arriver complètement bousillés
par l'alcool en seconde c'est qu'à 10h
ils sont déjà ivement si je peux me
permettre voilà ça a été dit et
troisièmement ils nous disent ben on est
démuni on est démuni je ne donnerai pas
le nom du lycée parce que je ne veux pas
stigmatiser mais il y en a un qui m'a
dit voilà je sais que j'ai 15 % d'élèves
qui sont au craque les parents sont
absents je fais quoi je ne sais pas
faire donc par rapport à ça Valérie PCR
a proposé justement aux établissements
des outils de pré prtion des outils de
diagnostic c'estàdire qu'on est là pour
accompagner les proviseurs s'ils ont
besoin par exemple de déverrouiller le
financement des tests salivair les tests
salivaires c'est un outil de
diagnostique qui permet tout simplement
à des conseills d'administration parce
que c'est après délibération du conseil
d'administration il n'est pas question
c'est même pas le proviseur pour vous
dire à quel point on laisse de la
souplesse aux établissements sont les
conseils d'administration qui décident
ou pas de proposer donc des tests
salivaires pour faire un état des lieux
de l'établissement et là encore on ne
choisit pas tel ou tel élève je vais
très vite Claude on choisit une classe
de seconde une classe de Première et
ensuite on a un pourcentage et ensuite
on accompagne justement la classe qui a
été en l'occurrence juger positive vers
des structures de prévention donc encore
une fois je le redis c'est de la
prévention notre bras armé sur la
prévention sera le criryps et Jean
spiriry je vois est au 2e rang qui est
également conseiller régional et
Brigitte Custer j'en profite hein quand
même parce que nous sommes collègues qui
est également conseiller régional et mer
du 17e arrondissement donc encore une
fois de la présention nous ne sommes pas
dans un système d'accusation mais de
prévention mais il y a pas seulement les
tests salivaires parce que là encore la
gauche nous a complètement caricaturé il
y a aussi des référents addiction qui
seront là pour parler avec des jeunes et
des jeunes lycéens relais parce qu'on
sait que la parole d'un jeune est
beaucoup plus impactante que celle d'un
adulte donc on va mettre en place tout
ça encore une fois je le redis il nous
faut du pragmatisme de la détermination
parce que sur ce sujet-là la gauche n'a
strictement rien fait et on voit les
résultat qui sont un véritable échec et
nous républicains justement nous voulons
affronter la réalité avec courage et
détermination oh là là c'est génial
merci agès merci alors voilà une table
ronde qui a été riche d'enseignement je
voudrais remercier christiel Prado pour
sa présence merci Daniel Fasquel
Marianne Montchamp Sophie goguin Valérie
Debord et Denis Jaca et nous allons
passer à une autre table ronde si vous
le voulez bien si vous pouvez rejoindre
votre place j'appelle évidemment Édouard
courcial Marc Philippe d'bress ERC vert
et ériic CTI la compagnie des éc mais
merci tout plein
d'être de nous rejoindre sur cette table
ronde alors je vous le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez compris évidemment au
travers de cette table ronde nous
voulons une une une France fraternelle
la fraternité c'est quelque chose
d'important mais pourtant nous voulons
aussi que notre système social notre
protection sociale soit fondée sur des
droits et des devoirs nous voulons bien
sûr lutter contre les abus pour un
système social plus juste voilà ce que
je je voulais vous dire en introduction
et inviter Édouard courcial à nous dire
ce qu'il pense aujourd'hui de cette
justice sociale et comment en matière de
droit et de devoir au sein de son
conseil départemental il agit pour nous
dire l'expérience de terrain dois-je
vous rappeler quand même qu'Édouard
courial est député de loise président du
conseil départemental de loise et
vice-président de des républicains merci
Édouard pour ton intervention merci
Claude je suis pas tout à fait
vice-président des républicains mais je
suis content que tu ai pensé que j'ai pu
l'être
voilà en tout état de cause merci de me
donner la parole pour apporter mon
témoignage de ce que je vis comme
président du conseil départemental de
loise et des enseignements que je
pourrais en tirer justement au niveau
national pour consolider notre système
de protection sociale d'ête sociale en
réalité il y a un an lorsque j'ai
récupéré les clés du département quand
je dis je l'ai s récupéré on me les a
pas donné en réalité je suis allé les
chercher j'ai trouvé une situation qui
est d'ailleurs caractéristique de ce que
vivent les conseil départementaux très
dégradé sur le plan financier nous
avions une baisse continue des dotations
et même surtout historique des dotations
de l'État et dans le même temps une
hausse sans commune mesure historique là
encore des prestations sociales que nous
n avions à payer la réalité c'est que
face à cette situation très dégradée
j'ai tout de suite essayé d'agir en me
disant la bonne solution est essayer de
contrôler un peu cette augmentation en
responsabilisant les bénéficiaires en
luttant contre la fraude autour de ses
allocation et ses prestations sociales
alors j'ai essayé de le faire tout de
suite avec quelque chose qui nous est
particulier cher Éric dans le
département de loi c'est qu'il existait
par exemple une aide au permis de
conduire pour les jeunes cette aide de
500 € était donnée sous condition de
ressources aux jeunes qui en faisaient
la demande sans aucune contrepartie nous
avons fait le choix nous dans l'Oise de
nous adresser non pas aux jeunes sous
conditions de ressources mais à tous les
jeunes habitants le département mais en
contrepartie de cette aide que nous
avons passé de 500 à 600 € nous avons
exigé que les jeunes donnent 70 heur de
leur temps à la collectivité aux
municipalités aux action aux
associations de personnes âgées de
personnes handicapées dans la vie quand
on reçoit une prestation ça paraît pas
aberrant qu'on donne un peu de son
énergie et de son temps pour la
collectivité c'est la moindre des
choses et inutile inu vous dire que ça a
rencontré un Fran succès aujourd'hui ce
sont plus de 2000 bénéficiaires que nous
comptons pour 2016 avec beaucoup de
communes et d'associations partenaires
c'était une marotte chez moi que
d'essayer de trouver des contreparties
aux prestations j'avais il y a quelques
années déposé une proposition de loi
d'ailleurs sur le fait que laallocation
de rentrée scolaire soit versée non plus
sous forme de virement bancaire
finalement assez anonyme et sans
contrôle mais sous forme de chèque àchat
rentréscolaire pour être certain que les
parents utilisent AB Bonn cet argent de
la collectivité donné pour que les
enfants puissent rentrer à l'école dans
de bonnes conditions alors évidemment
c'est cette affaire de passe permis
plutôt anecdotique mais pas tant que ça
parce que ça change aussi les esprits
dans le département de ceux qui touchent
des prestations sociales mais c'est vrai
qu'en terme de masse financière c'est
bien peu de chose comparé aux 108
millions que le RSA nous coûte dans le
département et pour cela on s'est
inspiré de ce qui se passe dans ce
merveilleux département des Alpes
Maritimes si bien
administré avec évidemment chez nous
aussi la déclinaison et la création
d'une cellule antifraude au RSA grosso
modo ce que nous avons fait c'est que
nous
avons créé trois postes d'agents que
nous avons pris en interne nous n'avons
évidemment plus les moyens de recruter
mais à qui nous avons confié la mission
et bien de contrôler les situations des
bénéficiaires du RSA s'appuyant ainsi
sur les travaux de la caisse
d'allocation familiale qui est
franchement débordé et qui n'a pas les
moyens d'assurer cette mission et donc
nous dépendons de son bon vouloir à la
Caisse d'Allocation familial qui nous
transmet des fichiers souvent incomplets
mais néanmoins on a mis en place cette
cellule antifraude avec un système aussi
de
graduation de pénalité il y a des
amendes administratives il y a la
possibilité de suspendre le versement du
RSA il y a aussi la possibilité pour
nous de déposer plainte et d'ors et déjà
après quelques premières semaines
de mise en place nous avons constaté
nous avons constaté qu'il y avait déjà
65 amend qui avait été dressé pour un
montant global de 70000 € vous voyez ça
paye très largement les trois personnes
qui sont chargées de pister cette fraude
alors on dépend du bon vouloir de la
caissise d'allocation familiale et c'est
donc pour cela que m'inspirant comme
Éric deliger l'a fait l'ancien président
du conseil départemental du Loiret dans
son département m'inspirant de cette
bonne pratique locale nous avons déposé
lui et moi une proposition de loi qui a
déjà reçu 60 signatures à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui va chercher d'abord
premier volet à vérifier que le parcours
d'inscription du bénéficiaire du RSA
soit bétonné en définitive que l'on ne
verse le RSA que lorsque le dossier est
valablement constitué et complet ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce qui nous
amène lorsque vous êtes élu à avoir des
bénéficiaires du RSA à qui on réclame
des indus donc nous disons mettons pas
la charue avant les bœfs V que le
dossier est complet vérifions que le
bénéficiaire respecte la charte des
droits et devoirs du citoyen qu'il
remarque son engagement à la République
là encore c'est la moindre des choses
lorsqu'on bénéficie d'une prestation
offire par la collectivité et puis enfin
on va lui demander et ce sera offert au
Département de la possibilité de
participer à des travaux d'intérêt
général et deuxième point deuxième grand
volet et bien on va systématiser j'en
parlais l'échange d'information entre la
caisse d'allocation familiale et ceux
qui possèdent l'information et juste
ement les départements pour éviter que
les départements soient de simples
convoyeurs de fond c'est-à-dire le RSA
décidé par son montant au niveau
national nombre de bénéficiaires
dépendant étroitement de la mauvaise
politique qui est le cas actuellement
économique du gouvernement et les
départements qui paye sans avoir la
possibilité de contrôler donc voilà mes
chers amis les quelques mots que je
voulais vous dire en ayant après un an
d'exercice de mandat la certitude encore
plus absolue que consolider notre
système social c'est responsable
abiliser les bénéficiaires qu'il se
rendent compte que l'argent public qui
permet ça ça n'est pas de l'argent
gratuit en échange de quoi il faut
réaffirmer son adhésion à la communauté
nationale c'est bien la moindre des
choses et c'est ce qu'il est ressorti de
cette première année d'expérience à la
tête de l'Oise merci merci merci
Édouard oui oui au travers de la
première intervention d'Edouard et je
suis convaincu celle d'Éric cioti que je
suis ravie d'accueillir puisqu'il est
aujourd'hui député du des Alpes
Maritimes mais également président du
conseil départemental des Alpes parmi
maritime j'y arrive secrétaire général
adjoint cette fois je me suis pas trompé
dans les compétences républicaines tout
cela évidemment va vous expliquer que
notre système social est d'une
complexité finalement ça génère une
opacité parfois même une forme
d'injustice et surtout un non respect
des droits et devoirs de chacun de nos
citoyens donc il faut absolument
simplifier les choses et cl ifier pour
que chacun d'entre nous sache ce dont il
doit pouvoir bénéficier ou ce qu'il doit
donner cher ERC je te laisse la parole
pour expliquer ton expérience dans le
département des Alpes Maritimes merci
beaucoup Claude je vais m'inscrire bien
entendu dans le même propos que vient de
prononcer Édouard courcial pour évoquer
cet enjeu majeur que constitue la lutte
contre la fraude sociale aujourd'hui la
frate sociale dans notre pays qu'elle
soit au niveau des cotisations ou des
prestations
est estimée selon la Cour des comptes
entre 20 et 25 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire selon les évaluation deux
fois plus que le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale ça veut dire aujourd'hui que si
on parvenait à réduire de moitié la
frotte sociale on supprimerait le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale donc
l'enjeu est majeur c'est naturellement
un enjeu budgétaire primordial au moment
où où on veut réduire les déficits et la
dépense publique c'est aussi un enjeu
social celui de permettre le
consentement et l'acceptation du modèle
social auquel nous sommes tous attachés
ce modèle social ne l'oublions jamais il
est financé par les cotisations sociales
il est financé par ceux qui travaillent
et ceux qui travaillent sont soumis à
une contribution et et d'autant plus que
nous avons ce gouvernement qui les a
assommés de charges et d'impôts mais ces
cotisations au cours des dernières
années ont été de plus en plus lourdes
nous sommes au bout de la rupture pour
ceux qui travaillent et d'autant plus
que quelquefois il ne perçoivent pas le
sens de leur cotisation donc le le
consentement à ces cotisations repose
dans un système équilibré où on est
certain que les prestations qui sont la
contrepartie des cotisations noublions
pas les prestations ne tombent pas du
ciel on voit la multiplication des
prestations et on a l'impression
qu'elles sont un peu irréel ou virtuel
et d'ailleurs François Hollande a très
bien résumé au cours d'une émission
télévisée il y a à peu près un an où on
l'interrogeait sur le coût du RSA et il
était dans ses émissions où c'est face
au Français je crois qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui lui parlait du cût du RSA
et il lui disait mais madame le RSA ça
coûte rien oui c'est l'état qui paye
voilà donc c'était c'était la logique et
et c'est quelque part la logique or
aujourd'hui on a cet enjeu social de
lutter contre la fraude sociale et c'est
aussi un enjeu moral parce que frauder
c'est voler on a ce débat dans nos
collectivités comme vient de le rappeler
Édouard Coural le département des Alpes
Maritimes il y a 4 ans s'est engagé dans
une politique déterminée de lutte contre
la fraude sociale on a créé la brigade
une brigade au sein des services de lut
contre la fraude sociale depuis 2011
nous avons récupéré 31 millions d'euros
31 millions d'euros de fonds publics
nous avons prononcé 531 amendes
administratives quelquefois jusqu'à 3000
€ et nous avons déposé
271 plaintes auprès des parquets de Nice
et de grâce qui ont été suivis par des
condamnation très sévère donc il y a
cette exigence il y a cette volonté mais
on voit que on manque d'outils qu'on
manque d'instruments pour mieux lutter
mieux combattre la frudte sociale donc
un des enjeux de cette convention un des
enjeux du projet que nous bâtissons
autour de Nicolas Sarkozi c'est de faire
de la lutte contre la fraude sociale une
priorité nationale et pour cela s'ans
donner les moyens alors quelques pistes
de proposition d'action je pense qu'il
faut généraliser dans toutes les
collectivité mais aussi dans tous les
services le
système
je
salue l'arrivée notre
président merci à Nicolas Sarkozi de
nous rejoindre je disais à l'instant que
lorsqu'il était Président de la
République il avait mis en place des
outils importants de lutte contre la
fraude sociale et notamment le registre
commun de toutes les prestations
sociales qui permettaiit d'éviter que
certaines personnes touchent le RSA dans
plusieurs départements par exemple ça a
été un progrès considérable en 2012
aujourd'hui nous pouvons et nous devons
aller plus loin pour combattre cette
fraudte sociale qui gangraine notre Pact
social alors quelques propositions très
claires je propose qu'on puisse accès
notamment pour le RSA accéder au compte
bancairirees pour les collectivités il
faut que alors que le le RSA est
aujourd'hui déclaratif c'est-à-dire que
chaque personne va se faire inscrire
sans qu'on contrôle préalablement ses
pièges justificatives qu'on puisse
vérifier ses ressources à avant qu'il ne
bénéficie de la location parce qu'après
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour la
récupérer je propose surtout que ceux
qui sont pris en flagrant des lits de
fraude qui sont condamnés que ça soit
administrativement ou pénalement soit
radiés du RSA et ne et des allocations
qu'il perçoivent et ne puissent pas se
réinscrire immédiatement je crois que
c'est essentiel il faut également qu'il
y ait dans chaque parquet un substitut
qui soit dédié à la lutte contre la
fraude sociale et il faut qu'il y ait en
même temps notamment pour ceux qui sont
inscrits au RSA cette obligation entre
équilibre cet équilibre entre droit et
devoir et notamment pour ceux qui
refusent deux offres d'emploi
successives qu'il puissent être radié ou
de Pôle emploi ou du RSA c'est une
question d'équilibre c'est une question
de notre maintien de notre pacte social
c'est une question de justice parce que
fraudé je le redis c'est volé et l'enjeu
il est majeur pour notre société c'est
la suppression de tout le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale si on divise par deux
le montant de la frotte sociale merci
claudci merci éic alors évidemment oui
combattre la fraude mais aussi il faut
comprendre pourquoi il y a fraude il y a
tellement tellement de de de de
prestations sociales qui sont au-delà de
27 et qui engendrent des droits connexes
que tout cela cette complexité engendre
des effets pervers et et il faut
absolument simplifier tout cela alors
comment simpli ier ce système pour qu'il
soit d'abord plus efficace donc plus
juste et que il faut absolument ne pas
oublier que l'opacité profite toujours
au même alors je demanderaiis à Marc
Philippe d'bress de pouvoir bien
intervenir ce sujet Marc Philippe
d'bress est député de looise président
non non non pardon excuse-moi député du
Nord mais je vais céder la parole à
Nicolas tout à l'heure ça va être très
bien donc Marc Philippe d'bress et
député du Nord maire de lamersa très
belle ville et il a quelques
propositions à nous faire justement de
simplification de ces aides sociales
indispensables pour aider celles et ceux
qui en ont besoin mais pour éviter
justement ces effets pervers de la
complexité merci Claude les deux
interventions que viennent de
faire Éric Coural et éic cotti et
Édouard
Coural
erti Édouard coursal sous le contrôle
d'Eric sont illustrantes d'un nécessaire
exercice de clarification qu'on doit
faire sur la question du politiquement
correct que vous voyez dans tous les
discours de prèsprésidentiel
actuellement il faut préserver notre
modèle social notre modèle social il est
à bout de souffle notre modèle social il
génère des déficits considérables notre
modèle social n'est plus maîtrisé il est
complexe il est juste et donc il faut
préserver les valeurs fondatrices qui
ont permis à la libération de créer un
modèle social bien sûr mais il faut
profondément rénover ce modèle social
pour le rendre d'une part équilibré en
termees financiers nous sommes le pays
du monde pas d'Europe nous sommes le
pays du monde qui consacrons le plus
d'argent à notre modèle social par
rapport en pourcentage de notre richesse
et d'autre part il faut essayer d'aller
directement sur les problèmes qui
permettront d'en sortir et quand je dis
nécessaire exercice de clarification
Édouard Eric viennent de vous illustrer
des droits et des devoirs et viennent de
vous illustrer que la gauche et la
droite c'est pas pareil la gauche elle
est dans une logique d'assistana
monsieur CUC qui vient de remettre un
rapport au Premier ministre sur la
fusion des des 10 allocations de minimas
sociaux que qui concerne le handicap la
vieillesse le RSA le RSO en outrem
l'allocation de F droit de chômage et
cetera pour n'en faire plus qu'une il
propose une allocation unique qui est en
fait un revenu universel minimal qui
serait d'ailleurs versé de 18 jusqu'à 65
ans c'est-à-dire qu'on est on étend au
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans et qui est une
pure logique d'assistana nous nous
sommes comme l'a dit cl tout à l'heure
dans une valeur de fraternité mais avec
une logique de responsabilité qui n'est
pas du tout la même chose et donc je
viens vous dire avec d'ailleurs tout
vous voyez que nous sommes tous à
beaucoup travailler sur les questions
dites sociales mais nous sommes dans une
dans une logique éic vert l'a écrit dans
le projet des républicains avec Isabelle
le calenec de on appelle ça revenu
d'activité unique ou revenus allocation
sociale unique qui permettrait d'aller
vers le regroupement de tout cela mais
dans une logique totalement différente
qui est une logique consistant à dire
quand il y a une allocation qui est
versée il y a des devoirs en
contrepartie il y a deux manières de
faire faire ce que Édouard a fait dans
l'Oise en rendant obligatoire un certain
nombre d'heures de travail en
contreparti du du RSA il y a une autre
manière de faire que j'avais abordé avec
le président Sarkozi il s'en souvient en
2011 non pas parce que je lui ai laissé
un souvenir une oubliable parce que
c'est le jour c'est le jour où avec
David Cameron il a déclaré décidé de
d'intervenir militairement en Libye et
pourtant il a passé 1 heure et3 avec moi
je peux vous dire dans le détail sur les
sujets du RSA et il avait accepté qu'on
exp expériment dans 10 départements le
fait qu'en contrepartie du RSA on rend
obligatoire à terme dans tous les
départements le fait d'avoir 7 à 10 he
d'activité et qu'on pouvait rendre ce
dispositif financièrement non non
contraignant pour les départements qui
en ont assez sur le sur le dos mais
aussi qu'on soit dans cette logique
d'insertion quand Martin h j'ai été le
rapporteur de la loi h j'ai été ensuite
le ministre qui a mis en œuvre le RSA
quand Martin HCH a proposé le RS
activité c'était bien pour qu'on passe
de la case
RMI ancien à la case activité avec un
parcours d'insertion obligatoire et avec
un certain nombre d'accompagnement dans
le département qui est le mial
département du Nord qui a toujours
refuser tout ce que l'on pouvait faire
en faveur de l'insertion qui a même
baissé son budget insertion on a 2 tiers
des allocataires qui sont dans une
logique d'assistana et on en a qu'un
tiers qui sont poussés vers une logique
d'emploi ou de le RSA activité le
président nouveau président des
républicains et son exécutif viennent de
changer cette logique en disant passe de
2/ ti3 on va passer dans une logique de
2 ti3 vers l'insertion et l'activité et
plus seulement qu'un/ers dans la logique
de l'ancien RMI si vous prenez ce que
proposent les socialistes et monsieurs
cirug vous allez passer en été je
rappelle en 2001 à peu près 500 millions
le coût du RMI et on on on on sera à
9illard 500 millions aujourd'hui le coût
du RSA et donc quelque part vous ê vous
allez être dans une logique de revenu
universel qui va coûter évidemment
beaucoup plus cher je ne dis pas qu'au
nom de la fraternité dans ce qui
concerne le handicap dans ce qui
concerne la vieillesse dans ce qui
concerne un certain nombre de personnes
qui ne sont pas en situation de
travailler pour des raisons de santé de
handicap d'inégalité des chances auquel
ils ne peuvent rien ou de de problèmes
d'isolement qu'il ne faut pas les
obliger systématiquement mais je dis que
aujourd'hui la loi permet déjà de faire
des choses que les présidents
républicains sont en train de faire et
que les présidents de gauche des
départements non'ont pas fait et je dis
que nous pouvons regrouper tout ça alors
si on est plus ambitieux Eric ce qu'il
propose dans ce projet des républicain
va plus loin forcément c'est un projet
de mandature
présidentielle on est sur 47 allocations
et évidemment et c'est l'ancien ministre
du Logement qui parle aussi évidemment
qu'il faut lier les questions de RSA et
de minimas sociaux avec les questions de
logement on passe son temps à ripoliner
à à ravuder des dispositifs à faire des
exceptions à des exceptions parce qu'on
est au bout du système le dernier sujet
et je m'arrête là c'est le sujet de
gouvernance on peut pas continuer comme
ça à avoir des CAF à avoir des
départements à avoir des allocations de
retour à l'emploi qui étaient géré pour
parti par pô emploi pour parti par les
département avoir les CCAS de de nos
mairies et d'avoir un parcours de saut
d'obstacle qui d'ailleurs et quelque
chose de totalement non fraternel pour
ceux qui subissent ce parcours qui doiv
faire c saut d'obstacle et ils
reviennent souvent à la case départ du
CSAS donc il faut un guichet unique
qu'on a d'ailleurs expérimenté aussi
sous l'autorité du président Sarkozi et
qui marche on l'a fait dans deux
départements tenu tenu par les ntres la
Côte d'Or et le Calvados ça marche le
guichet unique et donc on peut
parfaitement imaginer qu'il y a un seul
organisme payeur en fusionnant ce qui se
fait dans les départements et
aujourd'hui par les CAF et on peut
parfaitement imaginer qu'on a un guichet
unique et un contrôle de la fraude qui
puisse être aussi généré par ber si on
décide que la location sociale unique
est imposable et qu'on vérifie que
effectivement un certain nombre de
personnes remplissent bien les
caractéristiques pour être voilà donc je
m'arrête là tout ça pour vous dire que
le modèle social des républicains il
peut être fraternel il peut être
responsable mais c'est en aucun cas de
la
sistana voilà je vais avant de de céder
la parole à notre Président je vais
céder la parole à notre secrétaire génér
général er député de loise et et
et merci merci Claude juste un mot moi
j'ai un problème de positionnement je
suis entre deux poids lourds et et et
j'ai l'impression d'être un peu écrasé
par leur alors comme ils ont parlé
longtemps parler brièvement je il s'est
dit beaucoup de choses depuis ce matin
8h30 vraiment beaucoup de choses le
président Sarkozi va probablement
revenir sur tous ces sujets en faisant
des des propositions il y a eu beaucoup
de débats et je remercie Claude je
remercie Jean-Pierre et T ceux qui ont
animé cela Catherine évidemment au nom
de la famille et c'était c'était
formidable maintenant juste un mot sur
la location unique faut aller jusqu'au
bout du RSA la vérité c'est cela le RSA
était Nicolas une quelque chose de très
fort ça donnait non pas l'idée d'une
société qui empile des dispositifs
d'assistance sans jamais plus savoir
comment sortir mais c'était une idée de
de regroupement et également de
plafonnement au fond des choses par
rapport à des revenus d'activité
d'ailleurs le RS activité permettait de
dire il y a une différence au fond entre
entre le revenu de l'assistance et puis
le revenu du travail même sur même pour
des travailleurs dit pauvres
c'est-à-dire avec des tout petits
revenus donc ça incite à la reprise du
travail on n'est pas dans une société
d'assistana je crois que Marc Philippe
l'a très bien dit on peut pas être dans
une société d'assist mais on est dans
une société dans laquelle on doit être
fier d'assister ceux qui en ont besoin
et assister ceux qui en ont besoin c'est
évidemment d'essayer d'orienter toujours
ceux qu'ils peuvent ceux qui sont encore
en âge d'activité vers l'activité et
regrouper l'ensemble des dispositifs
sociaux en dehors évidemment des des des
des des prestations contributives
c'estàdire lorsqu'on a lorsqu'on s'est
assuré mais regrouper l'ensemble des
dispositifs plafonner ces dispositifs en
fonction par exemple du SMIC un certain
pourcentage du SMIC donner dimensionner
ces dispositifs en fonction de votre
composition familiale faire en sorte qu'
une logique de droit et de devoir
c'est-à-dire de contrepartie rendu à la
société à partir d'un certain temps dans
certaines conditions tout ça ne doit pas
être industrialisé ceci doit être fait
très humainement et en fonction des
personnes et quelque chose que nous
devons faire et lorsqu'on propose une
allocation unique c'est ça c'est cela
c'est bien un regroupement c'est bien un
plafonnement de cela par rapport au
revenus d'activité et c'est bien aussi
le fait de pouvoir la dimensionner en
fonction des des revenus familiaux et en
fonction de la de la famille je voulais
le dire parce que c'est une
proposition très très forte c'est une
proposition très claire c'est une
proposition aussi qui s'inscrit dans
dans le sens de la responsabilité nous
souhaitons une société responsable nous
souhaitons une société solidaire mais
pas une société d'assistana dans
lequelle tout le monde a à perdre et
notamment ceux aujourd'hui que l'on
assiste merci à
vous il me reste à à vous remercier tous
et toutes d'être venu si nombreux ce
matin et de vous donner l'envie de
partager ces valeurs que nous avons
nous-même partagé ce matin merci à tous
les interven les interventions de cette
convention et je cède la parole à notre
beau et bon
président